nach dem elfmeter drama in wembley
italien ist fußball europameister und
wird zu hause begeistert gefeiert
besserer corona schutz von kindern und
jugendlichen mediziner diskutieren über
eine impfpflicht für kita und
schulpersonal und neue hitzerekorde im
westen der usa waldbrände toben die
stromversorgung für kalifornien und
oregon ist in gefahr
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers willkommen in einer
neuen woche und guten abend in allen
christin ist auch heute dabei natürlich
und blickt auf einen spannenden abend
zurück aus sportlicher sehr sehr gern
einen krimi bis zum schluss mega
emotional und rein sportlich dieser em
absolut würdig italien ist zurück auf
europas fußball-thron tränenreich
dankbar und stolz sie haben ein ganzes
volk glücklich gemacht und das nicht nur
in italien selbst so soll das aus als
der italienische torwart gianluigi
donner roma den entscheidenden elfmeter
hielt bilder aus köln schreien herzen
tanzen und natürlich die autokorsos
überall auch in deutschland aber auch
auf der anderen seite des kanals in der
londoner innenstadt große gefühle
football's coming home dort beginnen wir
heute abend andreas postel ist unser
korrespondent als die alitalia maschine
aus london am frühen morgen in rom
landet ist europas fußball trophäe
zurück in italien 53 jahre nach dem
letzten em titel football's coming home
nach dem azurblauen rauschen beim ladies
quadratzoll
avisiert die magische nacht von rom
beginnt nach dem entscheidenden elfmeter
italienischen fans außer rand und band
corona und all die entbehrungen der
pandemie für einen großen fußball moment
ins abseits verdrängt es ist mehr als
ein sieg wir haben die trophäe in
england erobert das ist ein kapitel für
die geschichtsbücher fantastisch
europameister wir haben uns den titel
auswärts geholt
wunderschön wir sind sehr glücklich
[Musik]
von mailand bis palermo
ein land im ausnahmezustand
ausgelassen aber friedlich mit
autokorsos bis in den frühen morgen
an dem sich die schlagzeilen der
zeitungen überschlagen zu schön
der titel gehört uns wir sind die
champions
nachdem wir eine sehr schwierige zeit
wegen der koreaner pandemie durchgemacht
haben ist dieses erfolgserlebnis sehr
wichtig diese mannschaft hat von ihrer
em reise neben dem pokal vor allem
teamgeist mut und zuversicht mit nach
hause gebracht auch das würde ich die
italiens staatspräsident mit einem
empfang für die frischgebackenen
europameister im namen der ganzen
mannschaft wird mit italiens
nationaltrainer roberto mancini diesen
sieg am abend allen italienern die
europameisterschaft hat england also
nicht den seit 55 jahren ersehnten
großen titel gebracht dafür aber ein
lange vermisstes gefühl neben der großen
begeisterung das gefühl des stolzes auf
eine mannschaft die es bis ins finale
schaffte auf eine mannschaft die mit
einem kniefall vor jedem spiel gegen
rassismus eintritt aber auch das ist
teil der reaktionen nach dem spiel es
gab rassistische beleidigungen gegen die
drei glücklosen elfmeterschützen andreas
stammen berichtet bereit für den titel
nach jahrzehnten voller enttäuschungen
in minute zwei witthaus hoffnung glaube
10 66 minuten lang gefühlt europameister
am ende der tiefe fall
gegen englands angstgegner
elfmeterschießen ist kein kraut
gewachsen
dann werden wir halt weltmeister
schnell wird aus traurigkeit stolz auf
ein junges team voller vorbilder sozial
engagiert gegen rassismus oder
kinderarmut integrationsfiguren über
soziale ethnische und kulturelle grenzen
hinweg
sie haben uns alle zusammengebracht
gareth southgate und das team trotz all
der sportlichen kritik doch in der
niederlage zeigen sich auch die
hässlichen seiten denn die drei
englischen fehlschützen sucker sancho
und redford werden in den sozialen
netzwerken rassistisch beleidigt twitter
löscht mehr als 1000 einträge ein
wandgemälde von markus resch ford wird
verunstaltet doch zehntausende halten
dagegen darunter prinz william der es
als ein abscheuliches verhalten
brandmarkt die spieler haben mit ihrem
teamgeist ihrem gemeinschaftsgefühl so
viele teile des landes zusammen gebracht
darauf sollten sie unglaublich stolz
sein und ich glaube das sind sie auch
dass manche rassistisch beleidigt werden
ist unverzeihlich ist der traum vom
titel liegt in trümmern und zur
katerstimmung kommt die sorge dass die
party im ganzen land die korona zahlen
weiter steil nach oben treiben könnte
und die debatte verschärft ob die
regierung den heute beschlossenen
wegfall der korona beschränkungen ab 19
juli wirklich verantworten kann mehr zum
finalspiel nachher im sport bei uns und
wer die bilder dieser em noch einmal
revue passieren lassen will kann das bei
zdf heute.de und in unserer app dort
gibt es einen rückblick auf die gesamte
europameisterschaft im video in
großbritannien verweist der premier wir
haben es gerade gehört auf die impfquote
und will das ab kommender woche alle
coroner regeln fallen frankreich dagegen
wird einen anderen weg einschlagen auch
dort sorgt delta für immer mehr fälle
gleichzeitig beginnt sich bei den
menschen eine impfmüdigkeit breit zu
machen um eine neue welle abzuwenden
will präsident emanuel makro
durchgreifen
frage an thomas walde in paris ist denn
schon klar wie
erwartet wird dass die regierung hier
spürbar den druck erhöht sich impfen zu
lassen nachdem zahlreiche freundliche
appelle hier nicht die gewünschte
wirkung gezeigt haben
angedacht ist ganz offenbar eine
impfpflicht zumindest für bestimmte
berufsgruppen beispielsweise im
gesundheitswesen
angedacht ist ganz offensichtlich auch
dass wir am öffentlichen leben künftig
teilnehmen möchte nachweisen muss dass
er getestet oder geimpft ist bislang
hatte die regierung eine impfpflicht für
alle stets abgelehnt aber das wäre so
etwas wie eine impfpflicht durch die
hintertür
genaueres wissen dann in knapp einer
stunde wenn emanuel marcon sich aus dem
élysée an die französische nation wenden
er hat sich dank thomas walde leid für
uns in paris was die korona zahlen
angeht steht deutschland deutlich besser
da hat die bundesweite inzidenz immer
noch auf niedrigem niveau aber sie
steigt den sechsten tag in folge
aktuell liegt sie bei 6,4 gleichzeitig
geht es beim impfen voran knapp 43
prozent der menschen haben den vollen
schutz
und doch gibt es jetzt die diskussion ob
lehrerinnen und erzieher verpflichtet
werden sollten sich zu impfen um die
kinder zu schützen peter kunz eine
kindertagesstätte in braunschweig hier
müssen die kleinen keine große angst vor
ansteckenden erwachsenen haben alle
erzieherinnen sind freiwillig geimpft
weil jemand der hier arbeiteten nicht
geimpft ist der hat halt ganz großen
streu faktor innerhalb der kinder
innerhalb der elternschaft in gefahr
kann ihm die familien zurück getragen
werden dass es ja was anderes ob ich
allein in meinem büro sitzt und arbeitet
und nur für mich das risiko eingehe
denn kinder unter zwölf jahren die
selbst noch nicht geimpft werden können
könnten corona an angehörige übertragen
die schutz brauchen krebskranke zum
beispiel die aus medizinischen gründen
ohne impfung leben die meisten
lehrerinnen und betreuerin in kitas sind
ja schon geimpft aber für diejenigen die
sich bislang nicht haben impfen lassen
ist inzwischen doch druck erforderlich
ganz scharfen abgrenzung zu einer nicht
in frage
allgemeine nebenpflicht geht es hier um
eine berufsspezifische impfpflicht wann
also zur impfung für die die unsere
kinder beschulen und behüten an den
haaren herbeigezogen meint die
gewerkschaft unter den beschäftigten im
bildungsbereich insofern glaube ich
nicht dass das jetzt entscheide debatte
ist sind die debatte müsste meiner
meinung nach darum gehen wie kriegen wir
unser bildungssystem krisenfesten da
muss es um ganz andere dinge gehen
nämlich darum wie kriegen wir mehr
investitionen in die gebäude von schulen
damit sie eben in auch in pandemischen
zeiten nutzbar sind impfungen mit oder
ohne druck ist derzeit nur ein teil der
debatte die wir uns für den herbst
pandemie fester machen können die
bundesregierung warnt wir sind noch
nicht ausreichend gewappnet für den fall
dass die zahlen wieder wirklich stark
ansteigen so sollen auch die inzidenz
die messlatte für einen notbremsen alarm
bleiben ergänzt allerdings künftig durch
die anzahl der korona patienten auf
station im moment ist diese zahl niedrig
der ukrainische präsident wolodimir
zielinski ist zu besuch in berlin auf
der suche nach unterstützung
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
empfing in dem schloss bellevue und
jetzt gerade ist er im kanzleramt bei
angela merkel
dort dürfte es vor allem um die
situation in der ost ukraine und um das
verhältnis zu russland gehen und in dem
zusammenhang auch um nord stream zwei
die pipeline ermöglicht direkte
gaslieferungen von russland nach
deutschland und wird in der ukraine als
bedrohung gesehen
in den usa macht eine neue hitzewelle
menschen und natur schwer zu schaffen
für 30 millionen bewohner der westlichen
bundesstaaten gilt eine hitzewarnung vor
hohem gesundheitlichem risiko und
hunderte wald und buschbrände von
arizona bis rauf nach kanada besonders
dramatisch die lage in teilen von oregon
und kalifornien hier ist die
energieversorgung bedroht lück wallbott
berichtet die wälder der nördlichen
sierra nevada in kalifornien stehen in
flammen 2800 bewohner mussten evakuiert
werden ein schauplatz von fühlen
nach den verheerenden waldbränden im
letzten jahr steht die westküste von san
francisco bis vancouver wieder vor einem
katastrophensommer die
rekordtemperaturen haben schon 200
todesopfer gefordert 43 grad in phoenix
47 in las vegas und neuer rekord gestern
im kalifornischen death valley 56 grad
in den nationalparks herrscht höchste
warnstufe
es gibt im park ein wasser besucher
müssen trinkwasser dabei haben am besten
literweise es ist der heißeste juni in
den usa seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen
die talsperren wie hier der lopez see
nördlich von los angeles trocknen aus
der strom in kalifornien wird knapp weil
eine hochspannungs trasse vom feuer
zerstört wurde und die klimaanlagen im
dauerbetrieb sind
ich habe in kuwait im mittleren osten
gelebt das hier ist schlimmer
kaliforniens gouverneur hat den notstand
ausgerufen und die bevölkerung gebeten
dringend strom und wasser zu sparen
die hitze sei ein zeichen für den
klimawandel es ist unfassbar diese
hitzewelle
das sind auswirkungen des klimawandels
es ist real es ist durch den menschen
verursacht und es erreicht uns
jahrzehnte früher als die wissenschafts
modelle vorhergesagt hatte ein rasches
ende ist nicht in sicht die übermäßige
hitze wird nach angaben der meteorologen
weiter anhalten
zurück nach deutschland jetzt in der
sendung innenminister horst seehofer
spricht vom größten verbot einer
kriminellen rocker gruppe der deutsche
ableger der sogenannten bandidos ist ab
sofort aufgelöst bei razzien in mehreren
bundesländern waren anfang des monats
waffen drogen und große summen bargeld
sichergestellt wurden am morgen
durchsuchte die polizei treffs der
bandidos in nordrhein-westfalen und ließ
symbole an vereinsräumen entfernen
laut innenministerium wurden von den
bandidos straftaten nicht nur geduldet
sondern sogar belohnt
die polizei in hessen hat einiges an
ansehen verloren und viel vertrauen
es gab immer wieder negativschlagzeilen
vorgesetzte die nicht gegen
rechtsextremismus in den eigenen reihen
einschreiten skandale um rassistische
chat gruppen unzulässige daten abfragen
die schwarz grüne landesregierung ist
unter druck jetzt legen unabhängige
experten ihre empfehlungen vor
und deren dringender rat hessens polizei
braucht einen neuanfang sanderson tina
in den dienststellen frankfurt und
wiesbaden wurden zum beispiel personen
daten abgefragt etwa die der anwältin
setagaya wildes und der politikerin
janine wissler die kurz darauf nsu 2.0
drohschreiben bekamen außerdem waren
dutzende hessische polizisten in chat
gruppen organisiert in denen rechte
inhalte geteilt wurden
auch beamte des frankfurter s ca die
eingesetzte expertenkommission spricht
von einem kritischen moment für die
hessische polizei
es ist nicht nur nötig reformen
anzupacken sondern die so schnell und so
nachhaltig zu tun dass der neuanfang
wirklich für alle sichtbar wird dafür
ist dann der blick von außen ganz
wichtig wo eben nachgefragt wurde gibt
es etwa zum beispiel etwas wie ein
disziplinar register landesweit das gibt
es in der form bisher landesweit eben
noch nicht das werden wir entsprechend
aufbauen können außerdem soll unter
anderem ein neues leitbild erarbeitet
werden an dem sich alle polizisten des
landes beteiligen sollen polizeianwärter
sollen vor der einstellung regelmäßig
vom verfassungsschutz überprüft werden
und es soll eine öffentlichkeitsarbeit
geben die auch fehlverhalten
kommuniziert insgesamt gab es in hessen
sieben chat gruppen mit rund 50
polizisten und keiner hatte die rechten
inhalte gemeldet polizei wissenschaftler
begrüßen deshalb dass es künftig auch
einen unabhängigen polizei und
bürgerbeauftragten geben soll
genau die tatsache dass viele menschen
geschwiegen haben und zu gesehen haben
und nicht gemeldet haben dass
vorgesetzte nicht eingegriffen haben
das ist ein kultur problem der polizei
gegen rund hundert polizisten wird in
hessen wegen rechtsextremismus verdachts
ermittelt der handlungsbedarf ist groß
und jetzt nach südafrika wo seit tagen
heftige unruhen toben anhänger des
ehemaligen präsidenten jacob zuma
liefern sich straßenschlachten mit der
polizei und der armee
geschäfte werden geplündert und in brand
gesteckt sechs menschen kamen bislang
ums leben
der unter korruptionsvorwürfen stehende
summe hatte am mittwoch eine 15-monatige
haftstrafe angetreten
wegen missachtung des gerichts er war
einer vorladung der
untersuchungskommission nicht gefolgt
was zurzeit in kuba passiert hat es dort
seit jahrzehnten nicht gegeben proteste
gegen die sozialistische regierung
tausende wagten sich gestern auf die
straße und demonstrierten gegen
mangelwirtschaft und politische
unterdrückung
sie riefen freiheit freiheit wir haben
keine angst
mehrere menschen wurden festgenommen die
autoritäre regierung kubas macht
provokateure die von den usa gesteuert
würden für die proteste verantwortlich
in kuba regiert seit mehr als 60 jahren
die kommunistische partei
so jetzt kommen wir zum sport und ich
bin gespannt was es losgeht ist gespannt
bisschen nicht natürlich fußball
ein drama wenn männer weinen die gefühle
in dieser unvergesslichen fußball nacht
von london war ich extrem führung
ausgleich verlängerung dann das
nervenaufreibende elfmeterschießen mit
italienern im glücksrausch und
engländern deren traum jäh zerplatzt
es kann sehr einsam sein sogar im
wembley stadion sogar gemeinsam mit rund
70.000 zuschauern pokallos saka trifft
nicht italien wird europameister
held des abends und bester spieler des
turniers italiens 22-jähriger torhüter
donner roma die tragische rolle bleibt
dem erst 19-jährigen sucker dabei hatte
alles für die lions so gut begonnen
flugschau erzielt nach nur 116 sekunden
das 1 0
der früheste englische treffer in einem
spiel die erste halbzeit gehört den
engländern das muss auch italiens coach
mancini zu diesem zeitpunkt anerkennen
in der zweiten hälfte dreht italien auf
der ausgleich ist kein schönes aber ein
hart erkämpftes tor
leonardo bonucci nutzt seine chance die
verlängerung bleibt torlos
englands trainer southgate bei der
torschützen auswahl fürs
elfmeterschießen glücklos redford und
dortmund sancho hatte er extra dafür
eingewechselt beide treffen ebenso wenig
wie teenager sucker die spieler sollten
keine reue empfinden wir gewinnen und
verlieren als team italien nach
verpasster wm vor drei jahren nun
europameister
wenn du ganz unten und dann hast du die
richtigen leute die die wichtige kraft
finden um wieder rauszukommen aus dem
loch wir müssen uns vom trainer bedanken
die em ist geschichte mit tausenden im
stadion hoffentlich ohne corona effekt
ja nach der em ist vor den olympischen
sommerspielen in tokio die bereits in
elf tagen vor leeren rängen eröffnet
werden ein hoch um das deutsche team
sucht für den traditionellen einmarsch
der nationen 2
die fahne tragen
zum ersten mal werden eine frau und ein
mann gemeinsam team deutschland bei der
eröffnungsfeier ins stadion führen
zur wahl stehen unter anderem
tennisspielerin angelique kerber
beachvolleyballerinnen laura ludwig
wasserspringer patrick hausding und
turner andreas toba jetzt abstimmen
noch bis zum 18 juli auf sportstudio
punkt de la torre de schwierige
entscheidung absolut wir sind gespannt
und werden berichten wäre es dann
hinterher rennen sicher so von der
geburtsstation im wattenmeer an der
nordseeküste hat uns jetzt noch diese
nachricht erreicht die zahl der
neugeborenen kegelrobben steigt gute
nachricht wie schon in den letzten
jahren diesmal sind es knapp 2000 kleine
robben und auch die werden später mal
das größte raubtier der nordsee mit
großem appetit tagesration einer
ausgewachsenen robbe zehn kilo fisch
aktuell gibt es warnungen vor
stundenlangem dauerregen mit
hochwassergefahr für den westen und
südwesten von deutschland
es gibt morgen aber auch sonnenschein
und sommerhitze wie das alles
zusammenpasst hören wir gleich von katja
oliver ich empfehle ich natürlich das
heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber um 21.45 von uns war es das für
heute danke dass sie dabei waren und vom
ganzen team hier in allen einen
angenehmen abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend die ganze woche über werden
wir es mit dem unwetter tief bern zu tun
habe es bringt ergiebigen dauerregen mit
aber auch ganz heftige gewitter der von
gewittern durchsetzte dauerregen setzt
schon heute abend in der schweiz ein und
er breitet sich in der nacht über baden
württemberg rheinland pfalz und das
saarland und hessen weiter aus und wird
morgen auch nordrhein-westfalen
erreichen dazu gibt es heftige gewitter
zwischen ostbayern dem oberpfälzer und
bayerischen wald über thüringen bis
hinauf richtung sauerland morgen abend
von all dem bekommen sie im nordosten
deutschlands gar nichts mit heute nacht
ist es dort häufig klar und die
temperaturen sinken auf 18 bis 13 grad
und auch morgen bleibt es nordöstlich
der elbe sehr sonnig sonst gibt es
diesen heftigen dauerregen und an der
grenze zu dem sommerlichen heißen wetter
im nordosten entwickeln sich die
heftigsten gewitter denn morgen gibt es
krasse temperaturunterschied im osten
und im nordosten steigen die werte auf
28 bis 32 grad im dauerregen werden
dagegen kaum 17 grad erreicht
und auch in den nächsten tagen geht es
mit diesem dauerregen und mit den
heftigen gewittern weiter erst ab
freitag beruhigt sich die lage
guten abend